okay [ __ ] we're gonna be playing a
gang bang okay okay oh oh chef Joe my
help you need your opinion on viola the
winter my personal opinion is that she's
a useless [ __ ] don't personally however
she could their valuable information if
she can be trusted that's the real
question isn't it well that's good
timing hold on oh like I might paint if
you'd be willing not [ __ ] likely I
helped you hurt the morning star didn't
that prove to you I'm a woman in my work
people can go a long way to be [ __ ]
I'm tired of fighting against the saints
meet me and maybe you'll realize that
and wanna like time to find some answers
that cats do this is good the game back
a shack and si and this is so [ __ ]
slow jay says make sure to get the
[ __ ] I'll copper this [ __ ] is going
slow as [ __ ] it's like in the [ __ ]
fly jet full work mode you know what I'm
saying on that one night ok i blanched
right there just right there ok
nice ass come on come on [ __ ] be
[ __ ] and clits be [ __ ] okay here's a
sketch I like money yeah yeah big
[ __ ] hat now she's pretty hot I
didn't realize you would have patron of
the Arts viola we never really had the
chance to check what with you being a
science experiment yeah Sam I wouldn't
tell big guy look I'm not here to fight
we need to work together right Johnny's
dead because of you hmm Johnny's dead
because he thought he could do
everything on his own house tents so
what's in it for you I get to watch
kilbane suffer oh yeah [ __ ] twin dot
can you play nice look I'm always
gentlemen
it's a stag yeah yeah what is that
nothing good let's go
[ __ ] oh sure
gotta get my gosh
saints
i cat ladies first
yeah it's incredible out of here this
st. have taken cover with one of the de
winter sisters we're about to move in
Roger that contact me once you secure
the area said let's [ __ ] they're
[ __ ] tight with no lube let's do it
that's done let's hope the fronts clear
who were those guys soldiers of some
sort though I don't recognize me works
working for kill they may be evening
salutatorian stuff
this out okay that's it oh yeah we're
talking yeah
yeah I can't get in a [ __ ] ass all
sweaty Jesus what the [ __ ] of that whole
[ __ ] [ __ ] deaths on a stick all right
let's do that such as any better what
kind of jets are those
they've cut the power to the elderhood
robbing
[ __ ] tons of the
good God ok
come stag enemies
tell me you think it's going you'd have
to get pissy if you think you feeling
okay is another one I have another
[ __ ] there's a lot of these [ __ ] what
it's a noise
Oh chef
familiar a lick [ __ ] is that
Oh God
okay got ya you tell me next thing to be
after you for running seem in this city
what is down there
oh [ __ ] I like this guys [ __ ] fine oh
sorry I guess he just needed an easy
doesn't
what about Oh like sucking get out of
here that's [ __ ] daddy escape escape
it's gonna be safest you sure you can
get us there i'm sure i can try not sure
no hay que go now
thank you here we go there we go okay
let's tear this [ __ ] ass [ __ ] me into
the cop car now
I get in here yeah get on that rich
she gonna get in the [ __ ] get seedier
now so shy and buy that one yeah
Oh cat [ __ ] that ass
now looking I'm looking I'm looking shut
yo shut
buy me a drink
yeah I'll laugh was how about come on
on this scale just targeting us
then who hold them in worry about that
later right now i'm a bit busy
[ __ ] are we [ __ ] stuck no
oh [ __ ] is that a saint
chat okay [ __ ] it
look not just rocking her out of it [ __ ]
this car [ __ ] it sucks dick hole
she says
come on camera
oh oh you see in this I'm get support
for the credit these guys they're all
over be attacking anyone other than us
Oh No we've been busy working for cover
we're almost to the crib stay low it's
okay
chef how the [ __ ] is I like stuff flying
her out
ok
almost there though
I can't believe
yeah she's going in there
she's firing yes yes yes it's is the
real thing this is the real war
if I get
my name is Cyrus temple fun with a
special tactical anti-gang now special
taxes tag initiative how much duties are
one question please how long will snag
be occupying Steelport there is no
occupation we have the full support of
mayor rebels howl stag impact our daily
lives when we win the war on urban
terror you and your families will be
safe again sir that's not what I asked
let me tell you about Jessica parish a
girl from Stillwater who ran away from
home to be with her tough guy boyfriend
Jessica thought her life is huh until a
gangbanger kidnapped her through in a
trunk of a car and laughed as her
boyfriend crestor and monster truck
rally uh-huh if Jessica parish was your
daughter how far would you want me to go
thank you for your time okay okay thank
ya thank ya
it's out for Harambee